This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode
as we break down the psychology of our 20s. A bit of a universal truth about this decade is that nothing is set in stone. This is obviously one of the major periods in our life for exploration, for change, and that includes the jobs we work and our career path. I think in the past our careers were very much mapped out for us and restricted. We chose one career path and it kind of followed us through life.
And nowadays we have a lot more freedom and capacity for change. And I think it's really valuable to discuss how we could make that scary transition from one career to another, facing things like financial uncertainty, job insecurity during this decade. and making that decision because either we are unhappy with where we are, or we're just looking for something different, something more fulfilling, more us. Or maybe there's been a factor beyond our control, getting fired, for example, or just being burnt out. I think, honestly, our 20s are the best time for this change, and it might feel really scary
to start from scratch. You might not even know where to begin. But that is where our amazing guest comes in. we thought we might bring on an expert, the founder of Career Contessa, Lauren, to talk us through exactly how we can kind of change careers in our 20s and be sure of our decisions. So Lauren, thank you so much for coming on the show. Hi, thanks for having me. Firstly, can you tell us a bit about yourself and what you do? Yeah, absolutely. And then we'll get to the psychology of it. So my name's Lauren McGoodwin. I'm the founder and CEO of Career Contessa. We're the largest online professional
platform for women in their careers. Anybody can use our site, but we do, you know, mostly tailor our advice and content for women. And because women's careers are different, being a woman in the workplace is different. And really what we do is we help people, you know, get hired, get paid, advance at work, build these fulfilling careers. And the reality and kind of where the psychology piece of this kind of probably comes into is that mindset of like there's no one career for everybody, you know, there's not like linear career paths. One plus one doesn't always. equal to in your careers. And so what I set out to create was this resource that wasn't just a job site, which is what a lot of things are. They're like, get the job and then we're done with you.
I really wanted a career site that could build and grow with people as they navigate different transitions and shifts in their careers. So we do that at Career Contessa. We have a podcast called Career Contessa. I have a book called Power Moves. You know, we have all the things so that people can can continue to thrive in their workplace. I honestly love that. I wish I'd had a resource like that when I first, like, finished university because my, the only thing I really had access to was, like, seek and, like, that was it. Like, yeah. Seek and, like, the job page of, like, my university website.
So that is, like, super, super amazing. And I think such a great resource. I also love what you said where by one plus one doesn't always equal to when it comes to our careers. Yeah. It's very frustrating. Oh, yeah. But also it's super, it's really frustrating.
but it's also kind of freeing because sometimes you can equal four or like five. Yeah, exactly, exactly. Can I mean? Like, I'm thinking about my own kind of path through my 20s and like the little career dips and turns that I took. And like I started this decade working hospital. Then I worked as like in a call center. Then I worked as like an interviewer for the government. Then I was working as a consultant.
Like now I'm here. I feel like if that's what the first five years of my 20s has had for me, the last five months have. even more. So anyhow. Yes, absolutely. I like your optimistic view on all things. So far, this is great. I'm so glad. I'm so glad. And I feel, yeah, I feel like it's better to just approach things with this air of like, surely this is, this is all going to turn out okay. It leads to a lot of, one of my favorite quotes is, it's this or something better. And it's like, you know, what, because what is, what's the alternative? You're going to be like, it was this or my life was over. Like, you know, you don't want that either. So it's this or something better.
It's kind of been my new motto I love. Yeah, absolutely. We're going to talk about that more on a personal level later. But one of my first questions for you is, what are some of the common reasons why individuals, people like us in our 20s might consider changing careers? I mean, it happens for a whole variety of reasons. It can be that you kind of fell into a career. So maybe you found a job through your career center and it wasn't something you really wanted,
but it was better than nothing. and so you kind of were doing it and all of a sudden you're like, I don't want to do this the rest of my life. For example, my very first job out of college, mind you, I graduated during a recession, wasn't great. I was an admin assistant for a university. I didn't want to do that forever. I knew I didn't and I just sort of needed the time to, you know, obviously bills don't pay themselves. So you sometimes will take a bridge job while you are working toward wherever you want to go next. Sometimes it can be that, okay, I've started working and I have a huge interest in this other thing.
and I really want to maybe keep doing my job function, but in a different industry. And then you have the flip side where it's like, I want to stay in the same industry, but do something totally different. I had a really good friend. We worked on the recruiting team together at Hulu, and she made, in her 20s,
she transitioned from the recruiting team to the marketing team. Now she has a much bigger career in marketing. It was that transition that sort of was the first stepping stone. So I think this happens a lot. I also think in your 20s, you don't know what you don't know. And so one of the beautiful things about working and just taking something, getting out there, is that you start to get introduced to new things. And you start to follow your curiosity.
And so there's so many reasons why people might consider a career pivot, whether it's, I just want to do something different or I want, you know, more salary potential, someone who maybe decided they wanted to be a teacher. And they're like, you know what, I love this career, but I can't live off of this salary. So what can I do? So like people, you know, everyone has their personal reason. it, you know, it can be, I want to work remote. Okay, so what careers are going to allow you to do that forever?
So I think it all comes down to sort of people having a little bit more clarity about what they really want or something that really matters a lot to them. And it's like you can't always figure those things out thinking about them. You know, clarity comes from engagement, not thought. It's not my quote. That's Marie Forleo's, but I love it because you can't just sit there and think really hard and hope that the answer comes. you do have to get out there and start doing. And I feel like it's such an exercise of like value realignment. Because as we go through our 20s, the values that we held when we first maybe entered
the workplace and were making career-related decisions at like 16 and 17, like whilst we were still in high school, those values change. Maybe when you were 18 years old, you really valued money. And you really valued this idea of, I'm going to build all this wealth in my, in my 20s so that I can relax for the rest of my life and you get halfway through that and you realize this is incredibly unfulfilling and like not a life that I want to leave like I think there are so many factors that come down to finding something that aligns to who you are as you change and as your values change as well the other big one for me I think about this a lot I think our jobs are one of the
biggest time consumers in our lives, probably second only to sleep. And so not being happy with what you do for a living, with what you do every day for eight hours can suck a lot of life out of everything else you do. I think it can be an incredible source of stress and tension. I used to do when I was doing, like working in a call center, I would do mental health reviews and interviews for the government. And it was just eight hours of asking people about the worst and hardest points in their life, day in and day out. And it made me so miserable. And I didn't want to go to work. I would call in sick all the time. What do you think of some of the signs that we actually really do need to contemplate a change? It's not because we want to
do something that's more in line with our values. It's because, no, we seriously need to we seriously need to make a shift here. Yeah, I feel like your body usually tells you whether you want to listen or not, right? So I had this person I interviewed once and she said, your body will give you clues and the clues get louder when you don't pay attention to them. So, you know, a toxic workplace can impact you in a whole variety of ways. But if you kind of keep going up the scale, eventually, it's like, you know, people can experience like autoimmune disorders. And they're like, where did I get this? and you're like, oh, well, you've been extremely stressed for the last two years and like, okay, your body is responding to that.
You know, I think there's a lot of like little signs of people always want to know, like, is it me? Is it the job? You know, one of the things I do think is important to think about is like you take yourself wherever you go. So the first thing I would do of like if you're recognizing that is like do some, some of your own works, you know, work with a therapist, do some journaling exercises. Like some of these things that we talk about actually do work, you know, having
moments of mindfulness, disconnecting, like don't doom scroll. You know, start with some of those things because those are the things you can control. Maybe also the other thing I find for people is like sometimes they can't quite identify what it is that about work, you know, yours was obviously very obvious. Sometimes you're lucky and it is really obvious. And other times it's like you're being gaslighted by a boss who you don't quite understand that behavior. So education can help a lot with that too.
It's sort of educating yourself about toxic workplaces, manipulative. live bosses, you know, and start to kind of recognize those things because sometimes there's things that you can control, but we can't always control other people's actions. The other thing about boundaries I always think about is like when you think of a boundary, you're like no emails after 5 p.m. and you're almost like you're expecting your boss to not do that. But really the boundary is something that you set more for yourself, almost like a limit you're setting for yourself. So it's like, no, I'm not going to respond to emails after 5 p.m. I can't control that they send the emails after 5 p.m. But that's what I'm
going to do. So those are all kind of little tips, I would say, things to start with. If you're doing all those things and or you just know, this is not what I want to do. I'm so unhappy. I'm miserable. Look, I'm not, I'm not a person who would just naturally say like, just quit your job and find something else. I would be a person who says, because, and look, not everyone has that privilege. I was in a job that I absolutely hated. I cried in the bathroom. I got asked one day to feed paper through a printer. And I was like, they have to be kidding. This is like literally what this machine does. Like what do you mean I have to put paper one by one into the printer? I was so miserable. And the thing that helped me get clarity
and I think was like more of a positive outlet than just quitting my job was I started having informational interviews with people. I started reading books and listening to podcasts. I found another friend who was also a job searching and we connected once a week and we were setting many goals and, you know, having informational interviews. That job was never going to be the job for me. And looking back, there were so many parts about it that didn't align with my values and why I didn't love it. But I wasn't going to change that workplace. So instead I was like, what are some of the things I can control? Because I didn't have the ability to quit my job and focus on those things full time. But what I found is I was on cloud nine just by engaging in some of these things that
made me feel like there was hope that I wasn't going to be working in this job forever that I hated. So that's at least been my experience. Now, if you have the ability to, like, you've got some savings or you have, you know, some side skill that you can monetize and do some freelancing or side hustle or whatnot and you are able to quit your job, then maybe you quit your job because you're like, it's actually doing more harm for me to show up and keep doing this than it is for me to quit and, you know, make other sacrifices and other places. So there's a great book called Essentialism. and it's all about focus. And one of the things he talks about is like life is full of tradeoffs.
And I think that's really important because not everything can be a priority. Not everything can be your number one. So what are you willing to trade off? You know, are you willing to trade off, you know, the salary of this job that you hate to, you know, take a couple bridge jobs and look for a new job on the side, you know? Or are you able to say like, hey, I can stay here and kind of like decompartmentalize. like this job is not for me. I won't be here forever. And here are all the things I'm doing to take action to get myself out of here. So those are just some of the things that come to mind when I think
of like when people are trying to decide, should I stay or should I go? It really depends on your situation. You know, you have to know what your financial runway is. You have to know. And those are very empowering things too. You should know like, well, okay, don't have three months of, you know, the average job search right now is taking about five months, maybe even a little bit longer because it's a very tough job market out there. So for example, if you still have a job, you might say, I'm not going to quit because it's tough. So you have to take into account your own situation and some realities of what's happening and then make a strategy based on that. The goodness about the strategies, you can tweak it. You can refine it as you're going along. And like I said, I think a huge piece
of this is also finding some community. Find a friend who's also job searching. Find a community of people who are focused on this stuff because it will make you feel less alone. And it's one of the most important things when you are thinking about making a transition is talking to people who have been there and done that or going through it with you because they can relate. Yeah, absolutely. I think community is such an antidote to so many things. And you made such a good point. Like, I think obviously this is a podcast about psychology. And I think prioritizing your mental health is number one really like if the job is seriously causing you to feel mentally unwell I think it's hard to not be like well you should just quit and you should just like get out of
there because it's going to cost you a lot more and just like mental energy emotional energy time to recover from that emotional experience and I think obviously our mental health is like the most valuable resource that we have other than maybe like physical health. But it's also, like you said, it's really important to be realistic and to give yourself hope whilst you're still in that situation. Right. Like I think hope is such like a psychologically powerful emotion. I don't think I'm the first person to figure that out. But like it is it is so so powerful to keep you optimistic, to keep, you know, your spirits high, to. To keep. You know, your spirits high. to keep you motivated even whilst your environment and the job you're currently working is perhaps
really terrible and you're miserable and it's awful. The other thing that I wanted to say to that is I had someone on the show who said sometimes we change our external environment because there's something internally that we want to change. So it's an interesting thing when we talk about changing careers in our 20s because obviously in one hand I'm like yes absolutely take the risk to anything you can to try out a new version of you that you think you might be happier in. But I sometimes see cases whereby people continuously change their careers because they're using their careers as a proxy for something else that's wrong in their life. Totally. It's easier sometimes to change your career than to do deep internal work, right?
And also, I think it feels like a tangible thing sometimes, like your job title, your company, your boss, like the external environment feels very tangible. What I have found about psychology and internal work is like, that feels sometimes a little elusive, you know, like you can't quite hold that feeling in your hand even though you feel it, you know? It's like why psychologists will be like, name the emotion. You're like, I can't. And you're like, okay, well, step one, we've got to put some words to this sometimes, you know.
So I would agree with that. Absolutely. I think that's why I say you take yourself wherever you go. So if you don't do that work, you take, and I won't say baggage, but you take that to the next place. And you kind of collect these experiences and keep thinking, why aren't they changing? And you're like, but you only have control of yourself too. So it is, it is like the guest who said that. I completely understand.
And I think I see this a lot in job hopping where people will job hop and they'll say, well, I'm doing it because I want to get a higher salary and you're if you like peel back all the layers they're actually doing it because they like are afraid like they have massive imposter syndrome and they're afraid that the current company is going to realize they're not actually worth what they paid for them or like whatever like a thing like that and you're like oh okay well this is actually not about job hopping for like salary and career advancement this is this is a different thing altogether so I absolutely do see that as well. The other factor here that I was thinking about as well is burnout. Like if you were, if you were mentally so burnt out that you can't function at your job, I understand if,
I understand in some cases like if you're working as a nurse and working crazy hours and then you transition to like an admin job. Perhaps that would be better. But if you are burnt out, it does not just take like a career change to solve that. Nor does it take like quitting a job for it to go away. Like that burnout is like a deep emotional and physical state that needs to be addressed at a more holistic level. You might feel momentarily refreshed by changing careers or changing, more so in this area like changing jobs.
But it's going to come back really, really quickly if you don't establish like proper boundaries. And I think that's like another huge thing that maybe before you choose to change careers. is, you see what else is available to you in the current career and see whether there is room for you to be promoted, whether there is room for you to grow, whether there is room for you to upskill in some way, or whether there is room for you to just take like a long holiday, like a long paid vacation, which I know I'm saying this from a point of like, I'm in Australia and that is
we have long term paid leave. So I don't know if you guys have that. No, the US is like, I'm having heart surgery, I'll be delayed responding to your email. You know, our view on work is very unhealthy over here. But one thing I was going to say about your comment about burnout, this is what I have found. You can be working crazy long hours, but be really motivated and energized by what you're working on and you're not burnt out. I actually don't think burnout is always correlated to number of hours and whatnot. I think burnout is actually more correlated to the impact and the purpose.
So, for example, if you understand the impact that your work has on the company, the team, the product, the customers, whatever, I think that's much more energizing and keeps you from burning out because you understand your bigger impact. When I do this thing, here's how it adds to the bigger picture. When you are working crazy and you're just doing a ton of busy work and you feel like this work doesn't matter. Nobody cares about this work. Guess what? That is going to lead to burnout very. quickly. It's a one-way ticket to burnout in the sense of like sometimes I think it's more about the impact that your work is making because us as humans, part of our well-being is that purpose piece. It's wanting to make an impact. It's why, you know, trust fund babies who can sit on a beach all day long don't. You know, they don't, it's like it's not there's a piece of your well-being that wants to contribute and make an impact and be working on something that matters to you. And I think that, especially when you're younger in your career, look, you're not going to be given, like, some major big project or this, like, you're going to be asked to do some ground work. But, like, a way that you can rephrase this, like, I remember I got this advice early on that I really liked.
And it was, it was swallow the frog. And it's kind of like one of those greatest hacks. And I think it's helpful to learn it early on in your career is observe your boss, you know, figure out what they hate doing. and then learn how to do it and take it off their plate. Like, can you, you know, my point being is like sometimes early on in your career, nobody's going to come to you and say, do this thing, it will make a big impact in my day and therefore in your career. But you can, you know, job titles are just to start, you know, thinking about,
thinking outside the box of your job description, your job title, and thinking about, okay, what, what thing does my boss hate, but it matters to them? Could I learn it and take it off their plate? and therefore instead of doing these tasks that I feel like are busy work, I'm doing something that's truly helping and making a difference there. And that's just an example of like sometimes when you're younger in your career or earlier on in your career, there are some limitations, right? You're not going to be able to like take over that client or something like that.
But maybe you can do something to help support that. So I say that because, you know, I'm not trying to say, oh, your job description doesn't matter and you should take on all this extra work. I don't mean it like that, but it's like, where can you not just be the indispensable person at work where you work really hard and, you know, you're doing all the things? How can you be the invaluable person at work? What, what things really matter on this team? And I think that will help, one, grow your career, give you some more insights into like, you know, what lessons and tools and skills are you learning the add value, but also kind of combating that burnout piece as well. So I think that's one of the
things I find just especially early on in your career is like you can't look at it as as black and white as it is even though it feels that way. And that's what I was meaning about like one plus one doesn't always equal to. And you're right. It could equal four. But I think oftentimes people are just fresh because one plus one isn't even equaling to for them when it comes like they're like, they're like, I got the job title and I got this saying, why am I not fulfilled? Like I thought the key to, you know, career success and career fulfillment was as simple as like finding the right job at the right company and I worked really hard to get that way. And that probably goes back to a bigger picture. But this is also why I get frustrated with the terminology like dream job.
Do not talk to me about this. I hate that term. I literally did a whole episode of like the myth of the dream job. I was like, there is no dream job. Don't let them tell you that. Yeah, there is no job. And what it is, it's like this pumped up lifestyle version. And that's, that's a problem because also similar to a partner who is not going to check every box of your life. A job in a career is also not going
to do that. So we were talking about not dealing with your internal stuff. Some people are looking for that. They're looking for this job that will like check all these boxes. And then they're so disappointed when they get there and they're like, it's not what I thought it was going to be. And it's like, but maybe we need to peel this back and realize that your expectations of what you think a job, should be and what it owes you and whatever is unrealistic. And so you're on this constant cycle of, yes, the myth is what's keeping you stuck and unfulfilled more than any, more than any job or boss or anything like that is. Yeah, I totally agree.
And I have a friend who talks about this a lot. And she is someone who just like, she, she hates the idea of a dream job for the reason that her purpose is never going to lie in what she's getting paid to do. Like this is just something, like the thing that she loves the most in the world is not something she will ever get paid to do. And so it's, it's just really interesting to hear from her and her being like, I don't care where I work. I still have purpose.
I'm not going to, I'm not looking for my job to fulfill me 100%. Like that is not my job's job. What I mean? Like, that's not what I'm doing this for. I'm doing this for a paycheck. And the other thing that I'm, I absolutely love how you referred to relationships as well, there's the 90-10 rule which says that a lot of the time
我不会去，我不会指望我的工作能100%满足我的需求。这根本不是工作的职责。明白我的意思吗？这不是我做这份工作的目的。我做这份工作是为了拿薪水。我绝对喜欢你提到人际关系的那种说法，这里有个90-10法则，意思是很多时候
people throw away a relationship that is 90% fulfilling because they are missing their 10% and then they find someone who is the 10% and that doesn't last because they're like actually this is just like all the things I may have wanted but it sucks and I find that in careers as well
人们会抛弃一段90%都令人满意的关系，因为他们觉得缺少了那10%，然后他们去找一个符合这10%的人，但这往往持久不了，因为他们会发现其实这只是一些他们可能想要的东西，但整个人生却一团糟。我在职业生涯中也发现了这一点
and as someone who is I'm about to completely like double cross myself be a hypocrite as someone who is working their dream job like basically at this point, like this is the best job I could ever hope for, there are still times when it really sucks. And I think about going back, if I think about like going back to do hospital
作为一个即将完全反悔、成为伪君子的人——作为一个基本上正在做着梦想工作的人，此时此刻，这就是我能希望得到的最好的工作，但依然有许多时候工作真的很烂。而且当我回想，如果我想回到医院工作
or just something or something else because it's not secure. It's, there's just so many other factors that you give up, right? It's the trade-off as well. I feel like we're just talking, we're talking through so many hypotheticals here. I want to ask you like a very pointed question now. What do you have, what kind of advice do you have
或者做点别的什么，因为这份工作没有安全感。有太多的其他因素是你需要放弃的，对吧？这也是一种权衡。我觉得我们在这里讨论了太多假设性的情况。我现在想问你一个非常尖锐的问题。你对
someone who wants to change careers but is concerned about starting over financially. And you said it's taking five months. I don't have five months of savings. How do we probably prepare for that change? Yeah. Well, I think a couple of things. One, always be job searching in a way where, and what I mean by that is you should always be thinking about your personal and professional brand, upskilling, networking.
那些想要转换职业但又担心在财务上从头开始的人有什么样的建议？你刚才说这需要五个月。我没有五个月的积蓄。我们该如何为这种转变做好准备？是的。我认为有几点。第一，永远要以某种方式在寻找工作，我的意思是，你应该始终考虑你的个人和专业品牌、提升技能以及建立人脉。
Networking is not just with people you know. It can also be networking within your company, building relationships with people at work. Also networking, especially if you do want to make a career transition, when I often tell people as like, well, the people in your current network probably aren't going to be able to help you get to this new place because they're part of your old place. So you need to find what I call bridge connections, you know. So if you are, and here's the thing, you're not necessarily starting over, but would you be removing a like the security of a paycheck if you were to say,
建立人脉不仅仅是与你认识的人。它也可以是在公司内部建立人脉，与工作中的人建立关系。还有建立人脉，特别是如果你真的想进行职业转型，我经常对人们说，嗯，你目前人脉圈子里的人可能无法帮到你到达这个新的地方，因为他们属于你的老地方。所以你需要找到我所说的桥梁连接，你知道的。如果你正在，而且关键是，你并不一定是从头开始，但如果你要说
I'm going to quit my job and then find a new job or probably more more likely scenario is I was laid off and now I need to find a new job, right? So because most people I think in this job market if they want to switch jobs, they're probably going to keep their current job while they're searching. So let's just go with like you were laid off, you were fired or you don't have a job right now and you want to find something new. There is no, no harm in taking a quote, bridge job to create some income for yourself and have that as a tradeoff. while you are job searching. Nothing about taking, you know, the grocery store job or the job at the target means that you're there forever, right? Like your one move does not dictate the rest of your life. And also I would say like for someone who was a recruiter, I would actually be very impressed to be like, okay, you haven't had it. You've been job searching for four months. What have you been
“我要辞职然后找一份新工作”，或者更可能的情况是“我被解雇了，现在我需要找一份新工作”，对吧？因为我认为在这个就业市场上，大多数人如果想换工作，他们可能会在搜索的同时保留当前的工作。所以让我们假设你被解雇了、被炒了，或者你现在没有工作，想找点新工作。采用所谓的“过渡工作”来为自己创造一些收入，并以此作为权衡，这没有任何坏处在你找工作的时候。去做杂货店的工作或塔吉特百货的工作，并不意味着你要永远呆在那里，对吧？你的这一个举动并不能决定你的余生。另外我想说，对于一个曾经是招聘人员的人来说，如果看到你已经找了四个月的工作，我其实会留下非常深刻的印象，你会做
doing with your time? You're going to get asked a question like that. And so by being able to say like, you know, I walked dogs for the neighborhood. I took on babysitting. I did some freelancing of this and that. That shows me that you have drive and you take initiative and that you're hungry for something new. So, you know, being open about I'm making a career change, I'm doing something different, I think is like, and then connecting it to all the cool things that you're doing to get there. I think it's great. The other thing if you wanted to make a career transition right now or you, you were job searching. I think one of the best things you can do is go have informational interviews with people who are doing the job at ideally the company you want to work
什么来打发时间？你会被问到类似的问题。因此，当你能够说出诸如“我为社区遛狗，我兼职做保姆，我做了一些这个和那个的自由职业”时，这向我表明你有动力、有主动性，并且渴望新的事物。所以，坦承自己在进行职业转型、在做一些不同的事情，我认为这很好，然后把它与你为达到目标所做的所有酷炫事情联系起来，我认为这很棒。如果你现在想进行职业转型或者正在找工作，另一件我认为你能做的最好的事情，就是去和那些在理想中你想去的公司从事这份工作的人进行信息访谈
at. So can you learn from these informational interviews what the job is like there? Maybe what skills gaps that you have. Who do they hire? Why do they hire them? What do they look for to hire? What did they like about the culture? One of the things when I was working as an admin assistant hated my job and I really wanted to become a recruiter, I started having informational interviews with recruiters. Now, none of those informational interviews led me to a referral for a job. But what they did do is when I did get my job interview at Hulu for recruiting, I was able to tell them, I know I don't have prior, quote, quiet, you know, recruited. I don't have, quote, prior recruiting experience.
。所以你可以通过这些信息访谈了解那里的工作是什么样的？也许了解你有哪些技能差距。他们雇佣什么人？他们为什么要雇佣这些人？他们看重什么来决定录用？他们喜欢这里的文化是什么？当我作为行政助理工作时，我讨厌我的工作，我非常想成为一名招聘人员，我开始与招聘人员进行信息访谈。现在，这些信息访谈没有一个为我带来工作的内推。但它们确实做到的是，当我确实获得了Hulu招聘岗位的面试机会时，我能够告诉他们，我知道我没有之前所谓的、私下里的那种招聘经验，我没有所谓的、以往的招聘经验。
But what I do have is I've had 30 informational interviews with recruiters and I've learned this and this and this about recruiting. And here's how my experience, my transferable skills actually are a really good fit. So for example, in recruiting, you guys care a lot about candidate experience and I know this part's really important. I don't have candidates, but I work with students. Students are my candidates. And so I'm speaking the same language that they might be doing in an interview.
但我拥有的是，我与招聘人员进行了30次信息访谈，我了解了关于招聘的这个、那个以及那个。以下是我的经验、我的可迁移技能实际上如何非常契合。例如，在招聘中，你们非常关心候选人的体验，我知道这部分非常重要。我虽然没有候选人，但我与学生打交道。学生就是我的候选人。因此，我说的语言与他们在面试中可能会用到的语言是一样的。
And for the person on the other end, and I know this for a fact, I got the job at Hulu, obviously not because I was the most experienced, but definitely because I wanted the job the most. And I was, you know, going above and beyond. So do not let your prior experience or education or anything like that stop you. from the thing that you want to do. Part of it is creating a game plan of how are we going to connect the dots from where you are right now to where you're going to go next. And like I said, bridge jobs are totally appropriate, but we still want to be able to
对于对方来说，我很确定这一点，我得到了Hulu的工作，显然不是因为我最有经验，但绝对是因为我最想要这份工作。而且我，你知道，付出了加倍的努力。所以，不要让你的过往经验、教育背景或任何类似的东西阻碍你去做你想做的事情。其中的一部分是制定一个游戏计划，弄清楚如何将你现在所处的位置与你接下来要去的目的地连接起来。就像我说的，过渡工作完全合适，但我们仍然希望能够
have this informational interviews, you know, listen to podcasts, watch online courses about, you know, you want to be a community manager. What do they do? And then see if you can start to, you know, tailor your resume and tailor your LinkedIn profile and tailor your networking experience or what you talk about, the story that you tell people about yourself and your experience so that it's going to be very relevant to them. I have this quote that I heard someone say that I love, which is show the 10% of you that is 100% relevant to them. You know, they don't need to know your whole life story. They need to know like what part of you
进行这些信息访谈，你知道的，听播客，观看在线课程，比如，你想成为一名社区经理？他们是做什么的？然后看看你是否能开始，你知道的，调整你的简历，调整你的领英档案，调整你的人脉拓展经验，或者你谈论的话题，你向人们讲述的关于你自己和你的经验的故事，以便这些对他们来说非常相关。我有一句听到别人说的话我很喜欢，那就是：展示那10%与他们100%相关的自己。你知道，他们不需要知道你一生的全部故事。他们需要知道你的哪一部分
is going to be really important for them to know. If you're transitioning careers, it's not I quit my job where I got laid off. The point is I'm really excited about online marketing and here's what I've been doing to connect the dots between what I was doing before and why I want to get into and start in online marketing. That enthusiasm factor is massive. It is so massive because we were just talking about it. Sometimes people who have who have slided into this career and maybe burns out and stuck and not going to bring that same level of freshness and newness. that people like so desperately want. Yeah, it's like you can teach skills.
对他们来说非常重要。如果你正在转型职业，重点不是我辞职了或我被解雇了。重点是我对在线营销非常兴奋，以下是我为了将我以前所做的事情与我为什么想要进入并开始从事在线营销连接起来而做的事情。这种热情因素是巨大的。它是如此巨大，因为我们刚才还在讨论。有时那些悄然进入这个职业、可能已经精疲力竭、陷入困境且停滞不前的人，不会带来人们如此迫切渴望的那种新鲜感和新颖感。是的，就像你可以教技能一样。
You can't teach attitude. You know what I mean? Oh yeah. And you can't like breathe new life into someone. Like you know what I mean? Like you kind of have to cut. Yeah, I just think that's such a, it's actually such an asset.
你没法教态度。你知道我的意思吗？哦，是的。你也没法给某人注入新的活力。你知道我的意思吗？你基本上得……是的，我只是觉得这真的是一个资产。
Probably one of the reasons you got hired at Hulu as well. But you just said it's because you wanted it the most. And they knew that you were going to bring that into that job. Another thing that, um, one of my friends recently had an experience like that. And she has since. a much better job in a much different field and it's like a huge success story of what we're talking about and some of the things she did in the in the meantime was she taught herself a new skill
这可能也是你被Hulu录用的原因之一。但你刚才也说了，那是因为你最想要它。他们知道你会把这种心态带到那份工作中。另一件事，嗯，我的一个朋友最近也有过类似的经历。从那以后，她在另一个截然不同的领域找到了一份好得多的工作，这就像是我们一直在谈论的巨大成功故事，她在这一过程中做的一些事情包括她自学了一项新技能
she taught herself how to be really really good at excel which is super random I think if you've ever worked a corporate job you know how valuable excel is like I still know how to do all my functions from when I was a consultant like it's so valuable another one is like audio editing or um learning how to do design work. She taught herself a new skill and she also made her own project for her while she was job hunting. I always think about
她自学了如何精通Excel，这非常随机。我想如果你做过公司的工作，你就会知道Excel有多宝贵。我至今还知道我当顾问时所有函数怎么用，这太宝贵了。另一个例子是音频编辑，或者，呃，学习如何做设计工作。她自学了一项新技能，而且在找工作期间，她还为自己做了一个项目。我总是在想
what's that man's name? That famous man, Matt Damon. I always think about Matt Damon and Ben Affleck and how they weren't getting hired for jobs and they weren't getting like acting gigs and so they just were like, fuck it, I'm going to write my own script. And sometimes you need to do that.
那个男叫什么名字？那个著名的家伙，马特·达蒙。我总是想起马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克，他们当时得不到工作机会，也接不到演艺工作，所以他们就想，去他的，我要自己写剧本。有时候你就是得这么做。
Obviously it's not maybe won't make you into a quadruple millionaire that they are now. But just being like, oh, whilst I was, you know, unemployed, I, like, started my own business, like, doing reorganising, or I started my own business, like, selling online content, like, or help as, like, a social media manager, like, small things like that, that show, once again, that you have initiative, but also give you a new skill for you to bring into this new career. I think it's a misconception that to change careers, you suddenly, you need to go back to school or you need to get a whole new degree. Can you talk about that a bit? I think that's like a huge one
显然这可能不会让你像他们现在那样成为千万富翁。但只要想着，噢，当我在（你知道的）失业的时候，我（比如）创办了自己的业务，比如做收纳整理，或者我创办了自己的业务，比如销售在线内容，或者作为社交媒体经理提供帮助，诸如此类的小事，再次表明你有主动性，同时也为你带来了一项新技能，可以带入这个新职业中。我认为这是一个误区，即要改变职业，你突然需要重返学校或获得全新的学位。你能谈谈这个吗？我觉得这是一个巨大的误区
that I come across a lot. Yeah, I think that's why the informational interviews are so valuable because you can ask them, you know, would you hire someone who can, you know, has learned these skills via online learning and on the job and through real experience or do you prefer to see additional education and they'll probably tell you real life learning of the skills is more valuable to me than however many degrees you have now it always depends on what it is that you're doing if you want to be a doctor we need you to go through med school you know but i think it's i would not drop kick to paying for you know additional education before i've exhausted all of my free options and the ability to like for myself to test out and experiment and build things and um i would
我经常遇到这种情况。是的，我认为这就是信息访谈如此宝贵的原因，因为你可以问他们，你会不会雇佣一个通过在线学习、在职学习以及通过真实经验学到这些技能的人，还是你更喜欢看到额外的教育背景？他们可能会告诉你，技能的真实生活学习对我来说比你现在拥有多少学位更有价值。当然，这总是取决于你在做什么。如果你想成为一名医生，我们需要你经历医学院的学习，你知道的。但我认为，在我用尽所有免费选项、以及自己测试、试验和构建事物的能力之前，我是绝不会轻率地去花钱接受额外的教育的，嗯，我会
I would start there first 100 times over. It's really interesting because I actually, when you say like lived experience is better, I have a politics degree and I have a philosophy degree. Oh, and an economics degree. Do I use those? No, no. So like if someone, if I was to walk into like a position for an economist
首先从那个开始，一百遍也不嫌多。这真的很有趣，因为实际上，当你觉得生活经验更好时，我有一个政治学学位，还有一个哲学学位。哦，还有一个经济学学位。我用过这些吗？没有，没有。所以如果有人，如果我要去应聘一个经济学家的职位
and be like, oh yeah, I have a degree, but I've never done anything like this ever before, I really could probably only apply my knowledge from Munich. and that was years ago. Yeah. They're not going to hire me. I mean, experience is always going to speak much louder than degrees and words. You know, I think, you know, for a lot of people, having the college degree is like kind of
然后说，哦，是的，我有一个学位，但我以前从未做过类似的事情，我大概真的只能应用我在慕尼黑学到的知识，而那已经是多年前的事了。是的。他们不会雇佣我的。我的意思是，经验永远比学位和言辞更有说服力。你知道，我认为对于很多人来说，拥有大学学位就像是
that first step. But even now, today, like, I mean, my kids are really young. But if my kids get ready to go to college, I'm probably going to ask them, well, what are you studying? Is there? Because you might not even need to go to university at some point, you know? You might be able to learn everything via on the job learning and through, I mean, you can literally pretty much learn anything via YouTube videos if you really wanted to or TikTok videos at
第一步。但即使在今天，我的意思是，我的孩子还很小。但如果我的孩子们准备上大学，我可能会问他们，你们在学什么？有必要吗？因为在某些时候你甚至可能不需要去上大学，你知道的？你或许可以通过在职学习学到一切，而且我的意思是，如果你真的想的话，你几乎可以通过YouTube视频甚至TikTok视频学到任何东西
this point, you know? So I absolutely, especially for the advanced degree thing, I'm always hesitant to ever give the advice of like, yeah, go and pay for this thing. Now, some people are like, I need the accountability. I need to be able to show up in person. You're talking about something a little different. You could hire a career coach to help you and work with you. That would be a lot cheaper than going through an academic program. Oh, absolutely. Especially I find this a lot with my friends who are like, they've reached kind of like a plateau at like 25, 26. And a lot of them are like, I'm going to go do my masters. Because in Australia, like the government pays like, yeah, it's a lot easier to do it. The government pays your loan for you. And it's just like, it's just like almost like
这一点，你知道吗？所以我绝对，特别是对于高级学位这件事情，我总是对给出“去为这个东西花钱”的建议感到犹豫。现在，有些人会说，我需要监督。我需要能够亲自到场。你说的有点不同。你可以雇一个职业教练来帮助你并与你合作。那会比读一个学术项目便宜得多。哦，绝对的。特别是，我发现我的很多朋友经常这样，他们大约在25、26岁时遇到了某种瓶颈。他们中的很多人会说，我要去读我的硕士。因为在澳大利亚，政府会支付，是的，这样做容易得多。政府会帮你支付贷款。这就几乎像是一个
a limbo point. It's like taking a bridge job. You know, you're, you're like bridging between wherever you're going to go next and you're going to buy time. And I will say there are plenty of people in the U.S. that they just pay for it, which is not the best idea. But where they enroll in a master's program, they're like, I'm not totally sure what I want to do. And I'm kind of buy some time doing something productive. And so many of us, when you're in your 20s, the thing you know more than work is school. You know, you've been a student way longer than you've been a worker. Yeah. And especially when you're sold this very traditional path of like, more education equals more opportunities. Like, I don't necessarily think that's the case anymore, actually.
过渡期。就像找了一份过渡工作一样。你知道，你在无论接下来要去哪里之间搭起了一座桥梁，你在买时间。我得说，在美国有很多人，他们只是自掏腰包，这并不是最好的主意。但他们注册了一个硕士项目，他们会说，我不太确定我想做什么。我想通过做一些有成效的事情来争取一些时间。我们当中有很多人，当你二十多岁时，你比工作更了解的是学校。你当学生的时间比当员工的时间要长得多。是的。尤其是当你被灌输这种非常传统的路径，即“更多教育等于更多机会”。我的意思是，实际上我不再认为情况一定是这样的了。
and I think also I've been reading lots of articles about people being like actually like you said with your kids like it's a waste of money it's a waste of money for what I want to get into turning back to someone who is at that turning point at that crossroads
而且我也一直在阅读很多文章，人们说，实际上就像你对你的孩子所说的那样，这是在浪费钱，对于我想从事的行业来说，这纯粹是在浪费钱。回到正题，对于那些正处于那个转折点、那个十字路口的人来说
ready to change totally ready to find a new job ready to try whatever it takes to shift to this new path what are some of the key challenges you think they might encounter and how can they be prepared for them so that when they happen, they're not terrifying and cause them to retreat.
准备好改变，完全准备好寻找新工作，准备好付出一切代价转向这条新道路，你认为他们可能会遇到哪些关键挑战？他们该如何为之做好准备，这样当这些挑战发生时，它们就不会那么可怕并导致他们退缩。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析现代奇特世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上的 T-W-O-Percent，或者你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英国（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈 80 年代的快克（毒品）。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是想让大家知道这一点。
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会深陷于追逐之中
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，而我们仍然在追逐它，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），为什么你们觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure,
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战的序幕，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Marintini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What are some of the key challenges you think they might encounter? And how can they be prepared for them so that when they happen, they're not terrifying and cause them to retreat? Yeah. I mean, I will just say rejection is part of the process, right? So you're going to apply for jobs and not get them. You're going to have interviews that don't go well. You know, I,
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听播客《Love Trap》。你认为他们可能会遇到哪些关键挑战？他们该如何为之做好准备，以便当这些挑战发生时，它们不会那么可怕并导致他们退缩？是的。我的意思是，我只想说拒绝是这个过程的一部分，对吧？所以你会申请工作却没有得到。你会经历并不顺利的面试。你知道，我，
you're going to have informational interviews where you reach out and the person never gets back to you, you never get to have it. So, you know, part of this is trying to figure out what parts of this process can I control and what parts do I not have control over and also, um, not giving up because you had one bad moment. Like I, I joke that like if your resume got rejected, let's say they're spending it seven seconds on average looking at your resume. That's if they even did look at your resume. Like that can't be taken as a personal rejection and okay, you should give up because what does that person know, right? They spent seven seconds looking over something. But there are some tips that you can do that give you a better chance. Like for example, creating a really
你会经历一些信息型面试，你联系了对方，但对方从未回复你，你也从来没能进行面试。所以，你知道，这其中的一部分是试图弄清楚这个过程的哪些部分是我可以控制的，哪些部分是我无法控制的，还有，嗯，不要因为经历了一次糟糕的时刻就放弃。就像我，我开玩笑说，如果你的简历被拒绝了，比方说他们平均花七秒钟看你的简历。那还是在他们真的看了你简历的前提下。这不能被当作针对个人的拒绝，然后你就觉得好吧，你应该放弃，因为那个人懂什么呢？对吧？他们只花七秒钟浏览了一下。但你可以采取一些技巧，让你有更好的机会。比如，创建一个非常
great master resume and then tailoring that resume for each job that you apply for. That is something that is totally in your control. People always ask, how do I tailor it? You're going to tailor it based on what the job description and the company are looking for. So you're able to take your experience and how can you, again, take those transferable skills and make them work for what that company needs now? Can you, when you apply for a job, go back to that informational interview that you had at that job and say, I recently applied for this job, would you be able to refer me? Can I send my resume to you and you send it to a hiring manager?
棒的主简历，然后针对你申请的每一份工作对该简历进行定制。这是完全在你控制之中的事情。人们总是问，我该如何定制？你将根据职位描述和公司寻找的内容来进行定制。所以你能够拿出你的经验，然后如何再次将这些可转移的技能应用起来，让它们为该公司目前的需求服务？当你申请工作时，你能回到你在那份工作中所做过的信息型面试，并说，我最近申请了这份工作，你能为我写推荐信吗？我可以把我的简历发给你，然后你把它发给招聘经理吗？
That's within your control. You're able to send, you know, prep really well before an interview by researching the company, researching who you're going to interview with, sending a thank you note after. Those are things that you can control. You can have a practice interview with your best friend, your mom, your career coach, whoever. Those are things that you can control. I think that focusing on what you can control versus, you know, letting one thing kind of fall
这在你的控制范围内。你可以在面试前通过研究公司、研究你要面试的对象、在面试后发送感谢信来做好充分的准备。这些都是你可以控制的事情。你可以和你的最好朋友、你的妈妈、你的职业教练或其他任何人进行模拟面试。这些都是你可以控制的事情。我认为专注于你能控制的事情，而不是（让）一件事情有点脱节，然后它就会把你的整个局面都搞砸，这不是一个很好的生活经验。因为事情总会发生，你必须能够适应并执行B计划。我总是告诉人们的另一件事是，求职没有唯一正确的方法。所以你可以网申工作，盲目地在网上投递简历。也可以向你的人脉求助，如果你申请的工作是社交媒体经理，就为他们创建一个假的社交媒体账号，或者展示如果你被录用会创作的内容的真实图形。你拥有
out of place and then it kind of takes everything down for you. It's not, it's like an overall lesson in life. It's like that's not going to go very well because stuff happens and you have to to be able to adapt and go with plan B. The other thing I always tell people, I'm like, there's no one right way to job search. So like apply to jobs online, you know, cold apply to jobs online. Also ask your network, you know, create sample projects of like if the job you're applying to is a social media manager, create a fake social media account for them or show real graphics of the content you would create if you were to get hired there. Like you have the
展现最好的一面并控制这些事情的能力。现在，人们得到或得不到工作的原因有很多，我们并不总是能控制这些。而且，你知道，这是人类在对另一些人类做出决定。这就是为什么我这么说。求职中最糟糕的事情之一，而且我经常看到这种情况发生，就是人们没有获得进展。于是他们开始对自己的能力失去信心和希望。这就有点像这种不安全感和消极情绪。
ability to put your best foot forward and control those things. Now, there are so many reasons why people do and do not get jobs and we can't always control those. And, you know, it's humans making decisions about other humans. So that's why I say that. And one of the worst things that can happen in a job search and I see it happen all the time is like people don't start getting traction. So then they start to like really kind of lose faith and hope in their own abilities. And it's kind of like this insecurity and negativity. You know, imposter syndrome. versus a growth mindset sometimes is a slippery slope. You know, the growth mindset is the person who says, I'm going to get there and I trust in
相比之下，成长型思维有时是一条滑坡。你知道，成长型思维是这样的人：我能做到，我相信我有能力去学习、适应、坚持下去并保持韧性。而有冒名顶替综合症的人会想，你找不到工作是因为，你知道，你没那么优秀，反正你也不知道自己在做什么。总之，这本来就是一件渺茫的事。因此，能够管理这些想法也非常重要，是一项巨大的生活技能。这就是为什么我一直是这样的坚定支持者：找另一个和你一起求职的朋友。这样你们就可以分享这些事情，当需要的时候，他们可以做你的啦啦队长，反之亦然。我认为这一切都非常重要。
my ability to learn and adapt and keep going and be resilient. And the imposter syndrome person is, well, you're not getting jobs because, you know, you're not that good about, you don't really know what you're doing anyways. Like, this is a long shot anyways. And so being able to manage those thoughts is also really important and a huge life skill. So that's why I've always been a big fan of like, find another friend who is job searching with you. So you can share this stuff so that they can be your hype woman when you need to and vice versa. I think all of that is really important.
求职过程中有很多动态的环节。所以，是的。另一件事是，不要忘记 LinkedIn 的力量，拥有一个优化的个人资料，在 LinkedIn 上与人建立联系，留下互动的评论。我刚刚做了一整期关于 LinkedIn 评论力量的播客节目，这是你可以控制的事情，你知道的。所以我喜欢把人们的注意力拉回到你能控制的事情上，而不是你无法控制的事情。我要说的另一件事是，如果你处于那个阶段，想想你想申请的公司。所以有时候，说“我要申请任何我感兴趣的工作”会让人有点害怕。是的。因此，我一直很喜欢的方法之一——我并不是说这是唯一的方法——但如果你感到不知所措，通过说以下方式可以为你缩小范围：
And job searches, there's a lot of moving parts that happen with it. So yeah. And then the other thing is do not forget about the power of LinkedIn, having an optimized profile, networking with people on LinkedIn, leaving engaged comments. I just did an entire podcast episode about the power of LinkedIn comments. and that's something you have control over, you know. So I like to shift people back to the things that you can control versus the things you can't control. The other thing I would say is if you're in that part is think about the companies that you want to apply for. So sometimes it's a little scary to be like, I'm just going to apply to any job that comes at me that I'm interested. Yeah. And so one of the things I've always been a fan of, and I'm not saying this is the only way, but sometimes I feel like it can narrow it down a little bit for you if you're feeling overwhelmed by saying,
让我们只关注你的目标公司。为什么它们是你的目标公司？你只想为远程公司工作吗？你只想为那些你对其产品着迷的公司工作吗？你知道，你只想为那些登上“最佳职场”榜单的公司工作吗？你知道，诸如此类的事情。听着，没有人会去双重检查你的工作。所以它可以是出于任何原因。可能是因为它们有更好、更长的假期政策。我其实不在乎。我的重点是，弄清楚为什么这家公司让你感兴趣，你能否更深入地去了解它，并且，你知道，了解这家公司，听听他们领导者的播客，看看是否有你可以关注的财报电话会议。他们有你可以参加的活动或线上活动吗？你能在社交媒体上关注他们吗？
let's just focus on what are your target companies. Why are they your target companies? Do you only want to work for remote companies? Do you only want to work for companies whose products you're obsessed with? You know, do you only want to work for companies that are on the best companies to work for lists? You know, that kind of thing. Like, look, no one's like double checking your work. So it can be for any reason. It can be that they have a bigger, longer vacation policy. I don't really care. My point being is like get some clarity over why this company interests you and can you dive a little deeper to learn about it and, you know, learn about the company, listen to the podcasts with their leaders, see if they have earning calls that you can check in with. Do they have events that you can go to or online events? Can you follow them on social media?
你知道，所有这些事情积少成多。是的。我完全同意。这关乎于拥有探索性的心态。一种充满丰富性的心态，并心想：“我要得到这份工作，我要向他们展示我想要这份工作，我要敞开所有的门。”我可以，我最后一个问题作为结束。
You know, all of those things add up also. Yeah. I totally agree. It's about I think it's just like having an exploratory mindset. and one that's like one of abundance and being like, I'm going to get this job and I'm going to show them that I want this job and I'm going to keep all my doors open. Can I, I'm going to finish up by asking you one more question.
也许两个，也许两个。对于那些选择不太常规的职业道路、想要做一些不一定是通过 LinkedIn 或 Seek 申请的工作的人，你有什么建议？我想到的通常是创意类工作的人。摄影师、想要创业的人、播客创作者，诸如此类的人。是的，我认为对于任何开始做一些可能不是你在网上申请的工作的人来说，秘诀就是——直接开始。你知道，我的第一期播客节目不如我今天的播客节目好，但谢天谢地我开始了，我开始练习了，你知道，我就是去尝试了。我最近开始在 LinkedIn 上创作内容，我想，天哪，我的前五篇帖子其实没那么好。我当时并不了解在 LinkedIn 上撰写和格式化内容的最佳方式。猜怎么着？
Maybe two, maybe two. What advice would you give for someone who's taking a less conventional career path who wants to do something that's like not necessarily a job that you can apply for through LinkedIn or through seek. I'm thinking people normally like in creative jobs. Photographers, people who want to start their own businesses, podcasters, that kind of thing. Yeah, I think for anybody who's starting something that maybe isn't like a job that you
我每天都在坚持，不是因为我喜欢多做一件事，而是因为我想把它做好。所以如果你正在建立你自己的品牌或你自己的业务，有一点需要考虑的是：直接开始。然后通过开始，你将开始解决一些漏洞。与那些做你想做的事情的人建立联系，因为他们将是你最好的老师、倡导者，也是你可以求助的人。另一件事，我想可能从财务角度来看，就是：你将如何赚钱？你知道，
apply to online is like just get started. You know, my very first podcast episode is not as good as the podcast episode I have today, but thank goodness I started and I started practicing, you know, and I just got out there. I recently started creating content on LinkedIn, and I was like, oh my God, my first, like, five posts are not that good. I didn't understand, like, the best way to, like, write your content and format it on LinkedIn. And guess what?
如果你要成为一名摄影师，你打算如何向人们收费？你的套餐是什么？把事情列出来，而不是含糊其辞。我认为人们喜欢有选择，但不要太多选择，你知道，还要让他们能够轻松地做出这些决定。个人品牌加上营销，我想是所有这些工作中的一个重要部分。如果你要成为一名播客创作者，你将如何吸引人们来听你的节目？你是打算建好节目然后希望他们自己来吗？他们可能不会，对吧？所以你也会开始在 LinkedIn 上分享吗？你会在 Instagram 频道或 TikTok 上开始吗？你会
I keep doing it every day, not because I love having one more thing to do, but because I want to get better at it. So if you are, you know, building your own brand or your own business, something to think about is, like, just get started. And then by starting, you will start to iron out. some of the wrinkles. Connect with other people who are doing the stuff that you want to do because they will be your best teachers and advocates and people you can go to. The other thing, I guess, is probably on the financial standpoint is like, how are you going to make money? You know,
重新利用内容吗？所以，作为一个今天的创作者，我没有去上过学成为一名创作者，但我是通过边干边学、观察别人、阅读他们的博客文章，并在这一过程中不断迭代来学习的。我认为如果你走的是一条不那么传统的职业道路，它更具创意。这不仅要求你只做那件事。你可能还必须扮演其他角色，例如，如果你是一个播客创作者或者你拥有一个企业。你要明白你不仅仅是做播客。有时，你还得考虑税收和薪资之类的事情。所以只要记住这一点：运营企业除了制作本身之外，还需要一套完全不同的技能。我认为很多人开始创业是因为
like if you're going to be a photographer, like how are you planning on charging people? What are your packages? Like laying stuff out versus being a little loosey-goosey. I think people like to have options, not too many options, you know, and then also make. making it easy for them to make those decisions. And personal branding slash, you know, marketing, I guess is a big piece of all of that. You know, if you're going to be a podcaster, how are you going to get people to listen to your show? You know, are you just going to build it and then hope that they come? They probably won't, you know, so are you going to also start sharing it on LinkedIn? Are you going to start an Instagram channel on TikTok? Are you going to
他们觉得：我真的很喜欢摄影。好吧，可能还有其他职业道路也可以包含摄影，这并不一定意味着你必须自己创业。我想我对这一点也很敏感，因为我觉得有一段时间，至少在我这一代，千禧一代女性这一代，我们经常被告知：如果工作不顺心，就自己当老板，做一个所谓的“女老板”。我认为这也不是所有人的答案。所以我认为，对某些人来说，创业是一条绝佳的道路。而对另一些人来说，他们的想法是：我很有创造力，我喜欢创作，但我真的很想要一份安稳。没有哪一份工作能给你 100% 的安全感，但我希望在一家更大的公司里更大规模地去做这件事。你知道，
recycle the content? So, you know, as a content creator today, I don't, I didn't go to school to become a content creator, but I learned by doing and watching other people, reading their blog posts, you know, and just iterating along the way too. I think if you're doing a less traditional career path, it's something more creative. It just requires you to not just do that thing. You also probably are going to have to be like, for example, you're a podcast or you own a business. You understand you don't just get to podcast. Some days, you also have to think about like taxes and payroll or, you know, that kind of stuff. So just something to think about is that, you know, running a business is a whole other set of skills besides just that. I think a lot of people start running a business because
我想去 Canva 工作，在那里我帮助做设计工作或类似的事情。所以需要考虑的是：你究竟是一个什么样的人。创业伴随着巨大的高潮、低谷和不确定性。并不是说公司职场就没有这些。它有它自己的一堆麻烦事。你知道，外面的草并没有更绿。我曾在播客中请过一位女士，她说：你给哪里的草浇水，哪里的草就绿。就是这样。所以你想把时间和精力投入到哪里？因为无论你在哪里，你都得给草浇水。你必须这么做。你知道吗？关于为自己工作、成为一名自由职业者、创业或其他任何事情，我会说：
they're like, I really love photography. Well, there are probably other career paths that you can do that include photography and it doesn't necessarily mean that you have to start your own business. I think I'm also sensitive to this because I think for a while, at least my generation, the millennial women generation, I think we were constantly told if work isn't working for you, just become your own boss, become a quote, girl boss. And I don't think that's the answer for everybody either. So I think that for some people, entrepreneurship is a, is a great path. And for some people, it's like, I'm very creative and I like to create, but I really want the security. And no job is providing you 100% security, but like I want to do it on a larger scale for a bigger company. You know,
他们会说，我真的很喜欢摄影。好吧，可能还有其他职业道路可以让你从事摄影，这并不一定意味着你必须自己创业。我想我对这一点也很敏感，因为我觉得有一段时间，至少是我这一代人，也就是千禧一代女性，我觉得我们经常被告知，如果工作不适合你，就自己当老板，成为所谓的“女老板”。我认为这也不是所有人的答案。所以我觉得对某些人来说，创业是一条很好的道路。而对另一些人来说，他们会觉得我很富有创造力，喜欢创作，但我真的很想要安全感。虽然没有任何工作能给你百分之百的安全感，但我希望在一个更大的公司里大规模地去做这件事，你知道的，
I want to go work for Canva where I'm helping do design work or something like that. So just something to think about is like also who are you as a person. Entrepreneurship comes with high highs, low lows, uncertainty. It's not that a corporate career doesn't come with that. It comes with its own slew of things. You know, the grass is not greener anywhere. And I had this woman on the podcast who was like, the grass is green wherever you water it. And it's like, yeah. So where do you want to invest your time and energy? You know, because wherever you are, you're going to be watering the grass. You have to. And you know what? I will say this about working for yourself, being an on you're starting your own business, whatever it is.
我想去 Canva 工作，在那里我帮忙做设计工作或类似的事情。所以需要考虑的一点是，你究竟是一个怎样的人。创业伴随着极高的巅峰、极低的低谷和不确定性。并不是说企业职业生涯就没有这些。它也有自己的一系列问题。你知道，哪里的草都不是天然更绿的。我在播客里采访过一位女性，她说，你在哪里浇水，哪里的草就是绿的。确实如此。那么你想把时间和精力投资在哪里呢？你知道的，因为无论你在哪里，你都得给草浇水。你必须这样做。你知道吗？关于为自己工作、成为创业者、开始自己的生意或任何类似的事情，我要说的是：
You have to love what you're doing 150%, maybe even 200%, because when you start doing it for yourself, you're going to love it a lot less because you will suddenly have to deal with a lot of things that you didn't want to deal with. The one for me is like, obviously it's just like admin and taxes and talking to my lawyer and like things like that. And then it's also like receiving negative comments and doing social media. I did not start a podcast thinking that I would have to do social media as much as I did as I do. It's like such a hassle.
你必须150%甚至200%地热爱你正在做的事，因为当你开始为自己单干时，你会发现自己没那么喜欢它了，因为你突然需要处理很多你根本不想处理的事情。对我来说，很明显就是行政、税务、和我的律师沟通以及诸如此类的事情。然后还有接收负面评论和做社交媒体。我一开始做播客时，根本没想到自己要做这么多的社交媒体。这真的是太麻烦了。
And like I didn't go to school for that either. So I think it is about exactly the perfect place to end is exactly as you said, the grass is greenest, where you water it. And I honestly think that you can be watering two lawns at once waiting to shift over to that second lawn over there and let the other one die off. but it's like all about being realistic about like what you can achieve and in what time frame that's my I'm going to say that as a final piece of advice like you don't have to have it all sort it out in the next six months there's always this sense of like huge massive urgency in our 20s to get everything instantly sometimes it's going to take a little bit longer but it's still going to be worth it in the end look at that's a beautiful place to end I want to say thank you so
而且我也没有为此专门学过。所以我觉得，这正好是一个完美的结束语，就像你说的，哪里的草被浇灌，哪里就最绿。老实说，我觉得你可以同时浇灌两片草坪，一边等待着过渡到第二片草坪，让另一片枯萎。但这完全取决于你要对能够取得的成就以及在什么时间范围内保持现实。作为最后一条建议，我要说的是，你不必在接下来的六个月里把所有事情都理清楚。在我们二十多岁的时候，总有一种巨大的、强烈的紧迫感，想要立刻搞定一切。有时候这需要更长一点时间，但到头来它依然是值得的。看，这是一个完美的结尾。我想说非常感谢……
much Lauren for coming on honestly I was taking notes I think you could see of like your advice being like, oh, yep, I'm going to take that, going to pass that on. Like, it is genuinely so, so useful, so practical. If you want to hear more from Lauren, you should go and follow the Career Contessa podcast with Dear Media. I've actually listened to a few episodes, and you know what? I love when shows actually give you practical things to do. Yeah, that's pretty much what we do all the time.
劳伦，非常感谢你能来。老实说，我刚才一直在做笔记，我想你也能看出来，我会觉得：哦，对，我要把这条记下来，以后也要传达给别人。这真的是太有用、太实用 了。如果你想听到劳伦的更多分享，你应该去关注由Dear Media制作的《Career Contessa》播客。我其实听过好几期，你知道吗？我特别喜欢那种能真正给你提供实际操作方法的节目。对，这基本上就是我们一直在做的事。
You know, career advice delivered an actual bite size, like, do this, do this. I found that, again, career advice can sometimes be a little abstract and people like tangible. They need that in order to move forward. So that's what we do. Yeah, it's really, really useful if you're thinking about changing careers. Again, I will leave all of Lauren's links and career contessa links in the description of this episode. Thank you so much for listening. If you enjoyed it, please feel free to share with someone else who might get something out of this episode and leave a five-star review.
你知道，职业建议要落实在真正的小体量、可执行的具体行动上——比如“做这个，做这个”。我发现，职业建议有时会显得有点抽象，而人们需要具体的东西。他们需要这些来向前迈进。所以这就是我们在做的事。是的，如果你正考虑转行，这真的非常非常有帮助。再说一次，我会将劳伦的所有链接以及Career Contessa的链接放在本期节目的简介中。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时分享给其他可能会从中受益的人，并留下一个五星好评。
You can also follow us at That Psychology Podcast. If you have some feedback, something to say about this episode, further questions or, of course, an episode suggestion. We always love to hear from you. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
你也可以在“That Psychology Podcast”上关注我们。如果你对本期节目有什么反馈、意见、进一步的问题，或者当然，有任何节目选题建议，我们总是非常乐意听到你们的声音。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
我将为你剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，心理韧性、体能和建立复原力的科学。去经历一些艰难困苦吧，你将在另一端浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真的是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容小觑的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。